[Música]
voy a comenzar contándoles una historia
es una historia de una búsqueda cuando
yo tenía alrededor de 14 15 años
empezaba a ser muy claro para mí que la
vida era música que empezaba a tener una
necesidad de buscar este mundo que me
apasionaba y que apenas se estaba
abriendo para mí tocaba con mis
compañeros en el colegio y me di cuenta
de que para mí había un camino que se
empezaba a apartar de ellos porque ellos
les gustaba tocar un solo estilo y
estaban muy contentos y les encantaba
hacer esto sin embargo yo necesitaba
buscar más necesitaba encontrar
y en esta búsqueda y esta búsqueda me
llevo a encontrar a mi primer maestro de
guitarra clásica recuerdo este día por
la euforia con la cual yo llegué a mi
casa a contarles a mis padres lo que
había acontecido esta persona sentada a
mi lado miraba hacia el techo y yo
simplemente tocaba y él me decía no la
muñeca se te ha caído
necesitas levantar un poco más y en
increíble esta sensación esta cosa de
que yo sentía que tenía una persona que
prácticamente podía verme a través de
los dedos podía a través de solamente
escuchar podía sentir perfectamente cómo
estaba mi mano levanta el trasero me
decía y era increíble cómo la música
cambiaba totalmente
aquí encontré algo una cosa mucho más
grande que la vida y me decidí por
buscarlo me fui a chile
a perseguir una licenciatura en música y
esta llegada a una institución que
albergaba a más de mil artistas
chelistas pianistas cantantes teóricos
de la música no fue de alguna manera una
experiencia idílica o algo así como que
estás cumpliendo tus sueños y todo es
maravilloso me encontraba en un espacio
donde albergaba a más de 60 guitarristas
clásicos que querían tanto más que yo
hacer esto que tocaban mucho mejor que
yo y aquí fue donde encontré esta idea
de la obsesión yo me dije no haber nadie
que toque mejor que yo no haber nadie no
que toque mejor que yo que estudie o que
quiera esto más que yo y aquí fue donde
encontré la primera piedra de mi carrera
el ego
recuerdo haber me despertaba
he estudiado las dos horas que estudiaba
antes de irme a la universidad
normalmente y luego de haberme envuelto
de mis clases a casa después una pequeña
siesta y empezaba a sentir una cosa que
no iba bien hacer que mis manos hacia la
guitarra y en esa tarde me di cuenta por
fin que no podía tocar guitarra mis
dedos simplemente no eran capaz de
acercarse a los trastes
recuerdo haber llamado a mis padres a
bolivia llorando y diciéndole hasta aquí
llegó hasta aquí llegó mi sueño
y es que en este momento me di cuenta
que algo tenía que cambiar tenía que
replantearme las cosas tenía que
replantearme la técnica tenía que
replantearme la manera en cual yo estaba
proyectando me tomé por primera vez
conciencia de que había un proceso que
toma tiempo y hay que respetar
la segunda piedra fue un sueño
recurrente años después casi terminando
la carrera
era un sueño en el cual yo estaba dando
un recital
y cuando terminaba la gente aplaudía
como es correcto y yo me iba hacia los
camerinos con una sensación desagradable
como que algo no hubiera ido bien como
que algo estuviera sumamente mal y desde
mi estómago aparecía un agujero negro
que no solamente me consumía sino que
también es pelea de cuerdas rotas
astillas de guitarra era un sueño
terrible para mí y aquí fue donde me di
cuenta que el arte puede volverte loco
pero te puede volver loco si es que uno
no se ha hecho todavía las preguntas
correctas
había una pregunta que todavía rondaba y
que no me la había hecho claramente que
fue apareciendo cuando yo volví a
bolivia con un flamante título que decía
licencia de músico pero resulta que acá
en bolivia soy totalmente inempleables
no nadie me va a dar trabajo como
guitarrista clásico entonces empecé a
ver
la pregunta de forma mucho más clara
porque era muy claro para mí que mi vida
era la música
zoran era música
pero porque lo hacía
comencé a dar clases y aquí empecé a ver
todo aquello que había descubierto
cuando era joven con mis profesores
empecé a ver en mis alumnos las cosas
que estaban muy bien en el se reflejaban
claramente en la guitarra y como tocaba
y lo que hacía por ejemplo las personas
que son muy mentales tenían tienen una
técnica sumamente prolija pero es como
si no tuvieran les costará desarrollar
sus ideas y al contrario al revés hay
personas sumamente creativas pero
pareciera que estas ideas o esta
creatividad lo desborda y no pueden
darle forma en la técnica a la guitarra
me decidí por hacer una gira con uno con
un amigo de toda la vida que me llevó a
las ciudades más importantes de bolivia
santa cruz cochabamba la paz ciudades
intermedias como sucre tarija pequeños
pueblos inimaginablemente hermosos como
samaipata valle grande
y aquí fue donde empecé a darme cuenta
de esta pregunta de por qué lo hacía
una noche especialmente bella
especialmente inspiradora en sucre
con una audiencia muy cálida en un lugar
pequeño sumamente acogedor
luego de este concierto que fue muy
lindo
una amiga se me acerca y me dice algo
que me deja sumamente conmocionado se me
acerca a ella y me dice me has hecho
sentir
y eso acá en bolivia para los que no
saben tiene una connotación muy positiva
ella estaba expresando que la música que
lo que habíamos hecho le había movido
algo algo había cambiado en ella
en potosí después de una larga sesión de
prueba de sonido a una hora de empezar
el concierto sumamente cansado y con un
frío insoportable nos fuimos un lugar
que se llamaba la manzana mágica
recuerdo este lugar porque cuando
entramos la persona que lo atendía
levantó la mano y los ojos le brillaron
y nos dijo los vengo siguiendo desde la
paz me encanta su música claro nosotros
súper agradecidos contentos de este de
este evento los saludamos intercambiamos
unas cuantas palabras y proseguimos por
tomarnos el café por comer un poco para
tener por lo menos esos 20 minutos que
nos quedaban para concentrarnos ya y
empezar el concierto
cuando nos levantamos terminamos nos
acercamos a él y recuerdo esta es esa
mirada que él tenía en los ojos porque
desde su lugar humilde desde un lugar
donde no podía ir a ver el concierto
porque según sus palabras él tenía que
quedarse ahí a trabajar no iba a poder
haber versos con el concierto nos dijo
con una decisión muy difícil para él se
notaba no se preocupen chicos yo los
invito y se negó a pagar la cuenta
hace unos meses no sé cómo se me vino
esta idea de conformar una orquesta de
guitarras pero sí sé para qué sirven
jose carlos es un ingeniero comercial
pero la pasión a la música él enseña
natalia es ingeniera en sistemas pero
viene una familia sumamente musical
conozco a su tío en cochabamba que tiene
la biblioteca más increíble que yo haya
visto de música
y también entre otros está darién que
ejerce como mototaxista y con esto se
paga a sus clases de música porque según
él la música lo es todo para mí yo no
sirvo para nada más
qué es lo que hace que sea tan
importante la música recordemos la
próxima vez que vayamos a un concierto
que detalles tan sutiles como las
muñecas como pequeñas frases todo
aquello que está por debajo de lo obvio
puede realmente eventualmente cambiarle
la vida a alguien qué es lo que propicia
está conciencia silenciosa
y la pregunta ya la sabía la respuesta
ya las había no era yo ni los otros
tampoco ni lo que hacíamos era la música
esta conciencia silenciosa que no
solamente nos llama sino que también nos
une
gracias
[Aplausos]